i
[Música]
santa cruz de la sierra es el centro
agropecuario de bolivia este
departamento produce el 72 por ciento de
los alimentos del país incluida la soja
transgénica como del aparato
[Música]
reinaldo díaz conoce a todo el mundo en
ese aeropuerto muchos hacendados de
santacruz cambiaron hace tiempo el
todoterreno por la avioneta
[Música]
francia más lejana que
que tenemos como grupo familiar
está a tres horas de vuelo lo que
significaría en vehículo un día
un día y medio del viaje además de
ahorrar tiempo este sobrevuelo semanal
le permite controlar que no haya fallas
o plagas en sus cultivos
desde 2005 en bolivia está autorizado un
único cultivo transgénico la soja
resistente al glifosato en mayo de 2020
el gobierno interino de jeanine áñez
aprobó un decreto que podría dar luz
verde al ingreso de más semillas
transgénicas
esta es la soya miren el grano más o
menos esta no más de 2 milímetros
entonces ahorita yo le voy a mostrar
este es el grano de oro
junto al lobby de los productores
agrarios reinaldo impulsó el decreto que
establece procedimientos abreviados para
evaluar cinco nuevas especies entre
ellas el maíz y el algodón el objetivo
es duplicar la producción para 2050 pero
las comunidades indígenas se oponen por
miedo a que los transgénicos con también
en el maíz nativo que representa el 2
por ciento de los cultivos y restante
98%
estamos hablando de maíz duro amarillo
destinados al consumo animal y ese 98%
se siembra en esta región que estamos
ahora
donde no hay asentamientos de indígenas
entonces creemos que
desde desde el punto de vista de
coexistencia pueden convivir los dos
sistemas si se le prohíbe a bolivia de
contar con estas nuevas tecnologías en
estos distintos cultivos lo que va a
pasar es que se está coartando el
derecho a poder producir más y mejor
generar más fuentes de empleo generar
una balanza comercial más equilibrada
tres meses después de la publicación del
decreto un grupo de activistas interpuso
una acción popular contra las nuevas
semillas transgénicas a unos 250
kilómetros de santa cruz en la aldea de
agri encontramos ascenso herrera un
productor guaraní que lucha para
preservar el maíz nativo
debajo de la cama debajo de la cama está
más más guardado este el maíz blanco el
perla lo reemplaza al arroz
estas semillas fueron donadas por la
organización de la onu para la
agricultura y la alimentación con el fin
de paliar los efectos de una sequía que
duró dos años con la ayuda de la fao
varias aldeas indígenas están creando
bancos de semillas
esto va a otra manera este es el
el maíz el maíz negro que se utiliza
para el api vamos familia vamos al chaco
acompañamos a la familia de celso hasta
su plantación los grandes productores de
soja transgénica defienden que el
glifosato impacta menos el medio
ambiente porque reemplaza 2000 toneladas
de insecticidas y herbicidas por año
pero en 2015 la organización mundial de
la salud declaró el glifosato como
probablemente cancerígenos celso
prefiere fabricar un repelente natural a
base de ají y nosotros usemos en la
semilla transgénica donde nosotros
rechazamos eso no porque por experiencia
en mente no aguanta si bien no lo
cosecha inmediatamente lo tienen que
comercializar mientras que con nuestra
semilla nativa se conserva hasta dos
años si usted me dice que tengo que
producir más nuestras reservas nuestras
tierras nuestros árboles vamos a tener
que talar indiscriminadamente en
septiembre de 2020 una caravana de
productores agrarios se manifestó en
santa cruz a favor de los transgénicos
la meta
pocos días después la justicia boliviana
denegó la acción popular presentada por
los ecologistas pero todavía hay margen
para recurrir el estado tienen la
obligación de garantizar la seguridad
alimentaria a través de una alimentación
sana adecuada y suficiente para toda la
población la constitución boliviana
protege explícitamente las especies
nativas como el maíz nosotros tenemos un
equilibrio entre madre tierra y seres
humanos y en la madre tierra están los
animales y está la tierra y el agua
propiamente más allá de un debate
solamente científico tiene que haber un
debate sobre la cosmovisión de los
pueblos sobre la forma de vida que los
pueblos estamos adoptando dentro de
bolivia si bien la modernidad nos está
batallando en bolivia todavía subsisten
estos valores y este intento de tener un
equilibrio
la defensoría del pueblo pretende luchar
contra el decreto de los transgénicos
que considera inconstitucional pero la
presión de los empresarios puede
acelerar una revolución tecnológica que
parece inevitable